ladies turn my mic up please turn the
mic up please keep going don't stop
don't stop don't stop
Ricky keep going we needed
[Music]
don't stop Rickie's as everybody gets to
their seats right now don't stop this is
a wonderful year turn my mic up please
[Music]
Rickey minor turn it up God ladies and
gentlemen I know that we are in the
forty seven point five percent tax
bracket but it's time it's time to
celebrate marinate marinate break it
down now marinade
marinate even more ladies and gentlemen
intercepted naki plan if there's ever
been a time to be excited about cinema
is this year am I correct we need just a
little bit more of enthusiasm Tom Hanks
in the building right now marinate
marinate Merritt marinade this is
nothing against the years before this
year but this year the sharks in the
water the people that you've loved for a
long time have come to play in a big way
I see Leonardo DiCaprio out there in the
building right now ladies and gentleman
let it go
[Music]
how dance for you marinade marinade
oh and sitting next to Leonardo DiCaprio
is the chief director Quentin Tarantino
in the building
marinades marinade on it ladies and
gentlemen this is you to be excited
because I ran into a hero of mine I read
it - a hero of mine I'm gonna I'll see
if you can guess who does hero yes
ladies and gentlemen Eddie Murphy's in
the building right now
[Music]
stop and you [ __ ] Murphy get on
the stage man
[Applause]
[Music]
I absolutely have nothing plans yeah I
don't but just listen as as as a kid
watching you all these years man when I
see you out here as a kid growing up 58
he said you ain't that young
[ __ ] all I can say is Eddie I'm
glad that you here man and what I saw
and Dolomites listen I never put you on
the spot I love you that's all I want to
say I had to be on stage and you can we
get this picture for my Instagram
hashtag Eddie Murphy life give it up
[Music]
[Music]
in all seriousness ladies and gentlemen
this is a wonderful wonderful night they
told me I had to riff for three or four
minutes well all I could say is that if
you really enjoy cinema this year is a
special year because it's it's nothing
against the newcomers when you see the
newcomers it's always fantastic but when
you see your heroes giving us such great
work the irishman I mean I mean it just
feels great and I feel great and I'm
gonna get off the stage now cuz I think
my 3 or 4 minutes was so I see a Scorpio
in the building Scarlett Johansson in
the Vila
I just know your sign I don't know why I
know your sign does that make you feel
weird I don't know your sign Scorpios
birthday coming up you know just some
[ __ ]
Leo's a Scorpio to wear.i
acquaintance is the Aries and your wife
is a Scorpio see I'll be knowing [ __ ]
that's all I'm saying
but ladies and gentlemen on all
seriousness give it a freaky miner who's
been rocking rocking us for years
Scorpios
[Music]
marinate ladies you know but now it is
time it's my honor to introduce the
president of the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences ladies you
don't want to get on your feet right now
because we're filming this get on your
feet ladies in four days pin Rubin in
the middle
[Applause]
alright then good evening and welcome on
behalf of the Board of Governors of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences I would like to give special
thanks tonight to Jennifer Fox and her
team for producing this evening
celebration
this is actually Jennifer's second year
at the helm of these awards which which
proves that she has a producer's perfect
combination of leadership creativity and
a very short memory this evening we also
thanked Rolex for their continued
generosity and sponsorship a
long-standing champion of hearts and
we're grateful for the year-round
support of the Academy and particularly
the Academy's Museum of motion pictures
which will open in 2020 and that is a
promise that is a promise and you can
set the alarm on your Rolex right now so
this marks the unofficial start of award
season tonight is so different from
Oscar night in so many ways this isn't a
this is an anxiety free zone so rare in
this town so welcome and so needed this
is a Hollywood party in the best sense
it's an opportunity to celebrate for
family members in our filmmaking
community for their extraordinary
accomplishments not over the past year
but over time achievements that inspire
us and stand to leave a lasting imprint
on our culture for years to come
our presenters tonight will go into
detail why these individuals were chosen
what I'd like to know is how they were
chosen it all happens on one special
night a gathering of the Academy's 54
governors who rather joyously suggest
make speeches about lobby for and vote
on possible honorees with no
professional agendas it is just a robust
upbeat conversation about colleagues
whose work we love whose incredible
focus creativity and passion have
touched our hearts and minds and who've
made a difference at the end of the
night the Academy's president has the
rare pleasure of picking up the phone
and calling the chosen honorees
sometimes waking them up out of a deep
sleep and out of the blue telling them
that they're getting an Oscar this
ceremony is the result of the dedication
of our governor's volunteers
representing the Academy's seven
teen branches and I'd like to
acknowledge them for their commitment to
the Academy and to its mission and so we
can all thank you will our Board of
Governors please stand
okay sit-down meetings adjourned
as it turns out this year our four
honorees fall perfectly in line with
where our board hopes to lead the
Academy David Lynch represents David
Lynch represents the bold and fearless
creativity we encourage in all of our
members Geena Davis is tireless work
her work mirrors our own efforts toward
gender parity in the Academy's roster
we're doing it west duties sheer talent
West's sheer talent is emblematic of the
bar that we set
when we invite new members to join them
and lean Evert Miller
[Applause]
liyan Evert Miller is the ideal example
of why we have declared ourselves a
global Academy a community of filmmakers
from around the world welcome Lena and
now please raise a glass for a toast to
these honorees in gratitude for all
you've done for motion pictures for all
you mean to movie fans around the globe
and for the inspiration that you've
given us all Cheers
and Bravo